maybe there was a little bit of like
resentment deep in there now I wouldn't
change it but I think it needed the the
growth to get to that place Taylor
Lautner embracing his Twilight Fame
after previously feeling mixed emotions
exactly the actor speaks out during a
chat on the happy hour on Today Show
radio Taylor keeps it real about the
film series that put him on the map and
explains how his perspective changed now
only fond memories but I do think that
also needed the the space maybe there
was a little bit of like resentment deep
in there going like I I could have just
like experienced this part of normalcy
now I wouldn't change it but I think it
needed the the growth to get to that
place it's absolutely amazing I wouldn't
take back a thing yeah after starring as
werewolf Jacob Black in the worldwide
phenomenon Taylor realized
no
her life
so blessed it's been over a decade since
the fifth and final film was released
and Taylor he's got nothing but
gratitude I was always incredibly
thankful and feel super blessed for what
it brought me Taylor even has Twilight
to thank for meeting his now wife Taylor
Dome who was and is a complete tryhard
except for back in the day she wasn't
exactly Team Jacob did you ever look up
at that screen and say that's my man's
the problem is when she was watching it
she was saying that about Edward
yeah I was I was we all make mistakes
yeah we learn from them
let's face it
I am hotter than you
for a while there for the past few years
it was just like the twine mom stopping
me in the Stream the Twilight Saga
dropped five films between 2008 and
2012. and now it's found a new audience
only recently has it like resurged and
we have like these like young teenagers
you know starting to to watch it and it
is it's crazy to see it come back around
it feels good just knowing we have that
kind of support behind us Taylor
recently admitted despite its Newfound
popularity he didn't remember one of his
famous quotes
Bella
Bella where the hell have you been Loca
I would just start walking the streets
and people would come up to me and say
you know
you say where the hell have you been
Loca I'm like what
yeah can you say where the hell you been
Loca I'm like where the hell you been
Loca honestly I forgot that that was
even a line in the movie it's such like
a it's not an important line
and it just blew up it became this thing
but now like us Taylor's howling with
laughter now I like I get it I mean I
don't really get it but
again
[Music]